[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 les invités ravis de vous
retrouver voici le sommaire de ce jeudi
22 juin 2010 est depuis en temps le
théâtre alphonse daudet s'efforce de
programmes et de nombreux spectacles de
musique de danse et bien évidemment de
théâtre à coignières une programmation
éclectique sous le signe du
divertissement voulu par son directeur
et metteur en scène
l'occasion de parler de la programmation
2017 2018
sport nous allons également parlé d'une
discipline un peu méconnu le hockey sur
gazon un sport collectif qui se joue
avec une balle une crosse et qui oppose
deux équipes de 11 joueurs
le hockey sur gazon est un sport
olympique depuis 1908 et les yvelines
qu'on deux très bons clubs à saint
germain en laye et à versailles avec le
racing club de france met tout de suite
nous recevons pour parler théâtre
françois guillon vous êtes le directeur
du théâtre alphonse-daudet à coignières
bonsoir bonsoir vous alors tout d'abord
parlez nous de votre théâtre
alphonse-daudet depuis quand existe t-il
eh bien on va fêter le vingtième
anniversaire cette année puisqu'ils ont
il a été créé en 97 il a été construit
en 1997 et c'était un pari assez fou du
maire de l'époque qui qui est coignières
était une ville était toujours une ville
assez riche parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
il y avait beaucoup de taxes fiscales et
donc le la ville a pu s'offrir un très
beau théâtre est donc à chercher à un
directeur pour pour l'animer et donc moi
que j'étais très intéressé parce que
justement il y avait toute la
construction du théâtre il y avait tout
ça à mettre en place et puis à vraiment
à construire une action culturelle sur
un pays c'est mon métier c'est ça que
j'adore et qui est qui a été fait qui
marche très bien puisque maintenant le
théâtre à sa place dans le paysage
yvelinois parce que les pas simplement
le directeur vous êtes à même de théâtre
metteur en scène fait oui oui donc j'ai
toujours créé des
des spectacles en tant que metteur en
scène j'ai touché un pionnier en fait de
l'animation culturelle et j'ai créé
toute une action culturelle en normandie
et j'aime bien arriver défricher et puis
et puis construire l'action culturelle
avec les gens du coin et en mêlant un
petit peu les professionnels et les
amateurs quel et quelle tonalité voulez
vous donner à ce théâtre est ce que vous
y mettez votre pâte quant à la
programmation
oui tout à fait le théâtre devait
s'appeler ou départ andré malraux et
puis j'ai beaucoup aimé oui mais j'ai
dit que c'était un petit peu triste est
que ça correspondait pas là à la culture
que je que j'entendais faire et donc
comme la rue du moulin s'appelait la rue
du moulin à vent
et puis qui avait des lapins qui
couraient partout loua laisse construire
le théâtre on a pensé aux noms
d'alphonse daudet qui correspondait bien
à la culture légère distrayante agréable
mais si on gratte un petit peu il ya
toujours beaucoup d'émotion il ya
toujours beaucoup de choses et alphonse
daudet correspondait bien à l'image de
la culture que co que les élus et m'a
même bleu voulions y faire pas trop
sérieux et pas trop ce qu'on voit là
absolument et puis résolument optimiste
résolument gay parce que
il ya beaucoup de il fallait trouver sa
place aussi par rapport aux prix smile
en cours par rapport au théâtre de saint
quentin qui ont des programmes alors le
prisme passé beaucoup de têtes d'affiché
beaucoup de choses plus 50 ha c'est
beaucoup plus cultureux entre guillemets
plus intellectuel et c est donc le
théâtre de coignières à trouver sa place
dans une programmation de qualité
professionnelle est accessible à tous et
très éclectique
alors justement là on est ce qu'on peut
déjà faire un petit peu le bilan de
cette année
est-ce qu'il ya selon vous des
spectacles qui vous ont marqué plus que
d'autres ou qui ont eu plus de succès
des autres
le skieuse qui m'a surpris d'ailleurs le
gros spectacle qui a eu le plus grand
impact c'est le sait un concert de
sidney bechet du fils de sidney bechet
qui est venu rendre un hommage à son
père et c'était un concert absolument
merveilleux avec justement beaucoup de
souvenirs signer des chèques que c'est
une qualité musicale et les
enthousiasmer les
et vraiment les gens et c'était un
moment très très fort et de grandes
émotions voilà parce que pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas c'est le théâtre mais
il y à des spectacles de danse de
musique et de théâtre
absolument oui c'est très éclectique il
y a en gros il ya une vingtaine de
spectacles sur sur l'année et puis il ya
un tiers de théâtre un tiers de concert
et musique et puis un tir de danse voilà
alors là vous êtes vous avez déjà sorti
la programmation 2010 est de 1,18 vous
venez un peu nous en parler alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner quelques
détails concernant
on va dire on va commencer par le
théâtre peut-être oui alors le le
théâtre il ya moi il ya où il ya
beaucoup de compagnies régionales
puisque je travaille beaucoup avec des
compagnies professionnelles régionales
comme par exemple le théâtre des pays de
la loire
donc il n'y a pas de tête d'affiche
parce que les gens viennent voir at-elle
et c'est pas le but le but pour moi
c'est de voir de découvrir l'oeuvre et
puis la mise en scène et donc il ya par
exemple la sphère de la rue de lourcine
de labiche par le ter des pays de la
loire
il ya aussi le cas martin pige c'est à
c'est un espèce de vaudeville les
théâtres parisiens de il ya aussi il ya
aussi plus juste on sera pas exaucé ce
soir on peut retrouver tout ça sur votre
site internet c'est ça oui si l'ensemble
de la programmation avec des photos je
crois je l' ai vu un mot sur la musique
i am ou sur la danse
saison 2 mai 2010 alors le gros moment
de danse et le amstrong jazz balle est
qui qui est un très beau ballet ce avec
eux de la modern jazz qui est très
accessible et très très très bon niveau
et puis au niveau au niveau concert un
grand concert avec leurs castrale france
d'audi parce qu'on a un orchestre
symphonique alors fonce 2d et avec qui
va se mêler au plein jazz big band de 50
ha pour faire 1
donc ça fait une centaine de musiciens
sur scène parce qu'on a un très très
grand plateau qui de 300 mètres carrés
donc ça permet de faire des choses
énormes et puis par exemple on va
recevoir aussi un opéra de l'opéra
éclaté la périchole donc on est vraiment
sur un éclectisme dans vos choix dans
différentes disciplines
et puis justement une très très belle
salle faut quand même le dire mais elle
est très agréable salle de 400 places
avec un parking privé l'adresse et 26
rue du bois du moulin à vent à
coignières d'accord et puis si on a
besoin de retrouver la programmation
2010 et 2018 sur votre site internet
voilà parfait mais écoutez françois dire
je vous remercie beaucoup de votre
présence et on passe aux sports puisque
nous recevons notre autre invité tony
galipeau vous êtes responsable hockey
sur gazon au racing club de france à
versailles
je ne sais pas c'est l'occasion pour
nous de parler un petit peu d'une
discipline sportive méconnu le hockey
sur gazon
effectivement on connaît très peu et en
fait c'est un des plus vieux sport du
monde c'est un des plus beaux sports du
monde c'est le troisième sport en terme
de licenciés sur la planète aussi
on n'a pas l'impression comme ça mais
c'est un sport extrêmement pratique et
depuis maintenant pas mal de temps en
france et le racing club de france et
représente bien cette discipline
aujourd'hui avec une école de hockey où
on est capable depuis l'âge de 2 a battu
au moment où on commence à marcher vers
deux trois ans on peut mettre une crosse
dans les mains d'un enfant et lui
expliquer comment établir les techniques
de ce sport qui est essentiellement basé
sur la technique
est-ce qu'il faut savoir l'intérêt du
hockey sur gazon c'est qu'on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir un physique particulier
d'être coran ou petits n'importe quel
type de joueur peut réussir et percé
dans le hockey est un joueur et joueuse
parce que c'est un sport mixte
donc à partir du moment où on acquiert
le mouvement des épaules des poignets et
des mains pour manipuler la grosse tir
et faire des passes c'est vraiment
accessible à tous types tous types de
joueurs
contrairement aux fenêtres à l'idée
reçue on est plus proche du tennis ou du
golfe comme pratique que du hockey sur
glace avec l'équipement lourd et le choc
des joueurs complètement complètement
c'est un sport de non contact
extrêmement technique moi je dirais même
que c'est un sport moi la première fois
que j'ai vu le premier qualificatif qui
m'est venu à l'esprit c'est élégant
parce que c'est extrêmement élégant de
voir ses joueurs capables de parce qu'on
ne peut toucher la balle qu'avec une
seule partie de la crosse pas avec le
dos de la crosse
donc on est constamment obligés de
passer à droite et à gauche de la balle
pour pouvoir priver l'adversaire faire
des passes donc effectivement c'est
plutôt un sport basé sur l'élégance la
technicité la rapidité est bon le coup
d'oeil comme tout sport de sports
collectifs alors un sport très très
connu dans les pays anglo saxons
l'angleterre a exporté un petit peu ce
sport avec le cricket et d'autres un peu
partie exactement monde un sport donc
très connu et malgré tout en france pas
très connu nous avons
au moins dans les idées de la chance
d'avoir deux bons clubs nous avons saint
germain en laye qu'il ya un bon club
tout à fait un très bon club de kiel
hockey sur gazon et le racing club de
france à versailles à la boulie dont
fait partie le racing club de france qui
domine un peu championnat maintenant
depuis quelques années donc on a un
terme de titres féminins ont ce titre
féminin masculin on a 22 titres 23
pardon dont les trois derniers remporté
le titre de champion de france
et c'est vrai que comment dire c'est
c'est un club qui progresse énormément
parce que au niveau européen maintenant
on est dans le top 8 est dernier on
était dans le top 16 on est passé dans
le top 8
le championnat est effectivement repères
et plus de mini dominé par les équipes
belges néerlandaises et allemandes mais
le racing s'efforce effectivement de
progresser à ce niveau et l'année
prochaine on visera forcément un peu
plus haut pour pour notre club et c'est
vraiment les les objectifs pour l'année
prochaine j'espère que ce sport sera un
petit peu médiatisé alors est-ce que
vous souhaitez évidemment parce que là
ça passe toujours par des bons résultats
en équipe de france donc on a une très
belle équipe de france d'ailleurs dont
fait partie pas mal de joueurs du racing
club de france
donc étant donné que bon je pense que
paris va avoir va revoir les yeux on
aura l'occasion on va peut-être pas tout
de suite s'est prononcée optimiste j'ai
vraiment la sensation que ça va être le
cas ça serait pour le hockey une très
bonne occasion de faire connaître
expliqué dans un petit peu pourquoi
parce que c'est déjà un sport olympique
depuis 1908
voilà c'est un des plus vieux sport
olympique c'est un des plus est un des
sports les plus regardées aussi au
niveau télévisuel on
le sait pas mais c'est vrai que la
troisième audience télévisuelle aux jeux
olympiques le hockey sur gazon et
comment dire
c'est vrai que cette possibilité d'avoir
ses yeux à paris sera l'occasion pour
l'équipe de france de montrer
effectivement ce sport avec un très beau
site qui va être sur la ville de
colombes le site de hockey sur gazon
site sur lequel le racing club de france
est aussi très impliquée parce qu'on a
des on a déployé une section hockey sur
gazon au à colombes
donc maintenant on a en a deux sections
et on essaye de vraiment de faire en
sorte de développer ce club de le faire
connaître de faire connaître ce sport et
sa part sera évidemment d'abord par
l'équipe de france parce que c'est ce
que les gens vont d'abord regarder et ça
veut dire que les 6,2 de versailles
éventuellement de saint germain pourrait
servir de centre d'entraînement de
terrain d'entraînement pour des équipes
absolument y aura il y aura un terrain
d'entraînement à colombes mais le site
de la boulie pourra servir effectivement
d'entraînement puisque on a un
synthétique mouillé comme comme le
demande la la réglementation pour
pouvoir jouer sur le sec et moderne
c'est en fait voilà le terrain c'est
plus du gazon désormais voilà c'est plus
du gazon c'est un terrain synthétique
donc il faut mouiller qu'il faut arroser
parce que c'est un jeu qui est aussi
basé sur pas mal de deux glissades sur
sa même un petit peu de spectacle sur le
jeu donc ça permet aussi d'amener de la
vitesse donc c'est ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui à l'abri dernier mot c'est
un sport aussi donc on l'a dit pour les
enfants il y avait le week-end dernier
le challenge yala qui a rassemblé entre
400 et 500 ans 1 500 en france c'est
donc un vrai sport pour les enfants
à oui complètement sûr au niveau au
niveau national parce que c'est un
tournoi qui est connu au niveau national
et même international ya des équipes
étrangères aussi qui viennent au
challenge ya là donc cette année ça a
été un énorme succès avec 500 enfants
durant tout le week end eux
huit ans jusqu'à 14 ans 12 ans pardon
sont les catégories a qui viennent avec
les phases finales où le racing a encore
brillé et a remporté le titre du
challenge viala parce qu'on a vraiment
de très très belles équipes de jeunes et
très prometteuse pour la suite du club
et avec beaucoup de public
beaucoup y aussi un coup de pub lic une
activité qui est agréable à regarder
absolument là je conseille vraiment si
vous connaissez pas ce sport venu le
voir c'est vraiment très très beau à
regarder c'est très élégant très rapide
très spectaculaire ok tony galipeau
merci vous êtes responsable donc du
hockey sur gazon au racing club de
france à versailles merci beaucoup de
votre mois rappelle que tout à l'heure
nous recevions françois yvon le
directeur du théâtre alphonse daudet
merci encore
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
merci de votre fidélité vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission sur notre site
internet tv fil 78 points comme et
également sur notre application
bonsoir et à bientôt
[Musique]